boa tarde parece importante né mas é não
é muito muito importante não pessoas que
vivem do que amam são mais felizes
apontam estudos de quem os meus nome da
banda estaria eu sou mágico e eu comecei
a fazer mágica tinha 11 anos
eu percebi que eu conseguia controlar o
impossível e colocar isso na cabeça das
pessoas
era isso que eu queria a primeira vez
que eu vi a reação de uma pessoa como eu
fiz uma mágica
foi aí que eu falei para eu acho que eu
comecei a gostar desse negócio
eu sei que é estranho não vou ficar
fazendo mágica aqui agora não sei que
vocês podem achar que ele está com bomba
aqui dentro onde bicho só o que pude
quieto
não o tempo tempo tempo javi espinosa
assim a pressão se concentra só sei que
nem pisca dorme
bom enfim eu comecei a fazer marcha
quando tinha aproximadamente 11 anos
eu não lembro exatamente mas eu lembro
que acho que foi porque de mágica e e eu
eu amei tanto aquilo que eu estudava 9
horas por dia e eu não ficava mal e isso
dá nove horas por dia pelo contrário o
amava muito aquilo e eu estava sozinho o
computador como mora no interior não
tinha mágico então que quatro anos sem
ter contato com nenhum mágico e foi
nesse momento que já comecei a
questionar a escola porque eu odiava pra
ir para um lugar que eu tinha que ficar
preso em que eu queria estudar uma coisa
e eu não podia e eu ficava do computador
9 horas 10 horas ou então em casa
treinando na mãe chegava filhos e não
está estudando o que está fazendo isso é
só um pequeno computador mas não eu
estava estudando aqui eu amava fazer
aquilo
foi aí que começa a reparar eu encontrei
esse meio mágico e eu via pessoas que
elas amavam tanto fazer o que elas
faziam que elas acordavam estudando
aquilo elas iam dormir tudo aquilo elas
ficavam almoçando estudando aquilo foi
eu comecei a juntar dinheiro para poder
participar de um congresso de mágica e
foi aí que eu tive que trabalhar de
verdade eu comecei a trabalhar em uma
empresa de festas e eu sou muito muito
muito organizado eu trabalhava na parte
de organização
a minha sorte era que meu chefe era
mágico e muito paciente já explodir um
botijão eu mandava coisa errada a festa
enfim eu fiquei quase um ano trabalhando
de segunda a segunda
para juntar dinheiro para poder ir pra
esse congresso hora que eu cheguei lá
foi loucura total
a gente acordava às 7 horas da manhã no
café da manhã os caras com um baralho
manhã a manhã fazendo mágica hora do
almoço fazendo mágica e as conferências
congressos a noite e dormir 3 horas da
manhã fazendo mágica eu falei para eu
acho que encontrei meu grupo e foi nesse
meio termo quem encontrei o clã é o
palhaço
eu também achei meio de pessoas que elas
dariam tudo para viver daquilo por que
elas sentiam muito bem fazendo que elas
faziam e elas conseguiram transmitir
alegria através daquelas amava fazer e
eu voltei desse congresso já muito
decidida a fazer a viver de mágica e
melhorar minha parte artística então
fiquei mais uns quatro cinco meses
estudando mágica e cheguei com meus pais
falei eu acho que eu encontrei eu quero
fazer e eu também vou te dar uma outra
área eu acho meu pai ficou torcendo
administração administração porém não
quer estudar e palhaço
então foi foi meio difícil pra ele sair
eu entenda e só quem tenta viver de arte
sabe que não é fácil mesmo sendo de um
banco de classe média nos quais eles não
tinham como bancário com pagar 20 reais
no baralho e falou que quer baralho
então vai trabalhar então eu comecei a
investir em marketing para poder
divulgar meu trabalho eu parei um pouco
de fazer mágica mas não deixa de lado
como acessar outras áreas artísticas
comecei a fazer teatro
comecei a participar de saraus de poesia
comecei a escrever e nesse meio tempo eu
gostava muito do som do acordeon e eu já
tinha estava acostumando aprender tudo
sozinho e eu falei minha mãe é mãe
amanhã tenho paz são paulo comprou
accordion ela falou tá aqui meu cartão
falei mãe alguma coisa tá errado eu fui
comprar o acordeão voltei e comecei a
aprender e eu e eu descobri que quando
você quer muito a aprender uma coisa
naturalmente você vai conseguir é legal
também você conviver com pessoas que
fazem aquilo é legal você talvez pagava
aprender aquilo mas quando você se foca
muito você consegue aprender
tranquilamente
e aí eu comecei a trabalhar no fórum na
parte da administração
e eu fiquei uns três meses lá até que a
antiga as férias voltei das férias e
olhei meu chefe me sentei na mesa olhei
pra frente e falei que eu estou fazendo
aqui
eu olhei meu chefe a lei proposta de
demissão e falou pode eu peguei na
mochila e sair
cheguei em casa era férias ainda meus
pais e meu pai ficou puto da vida que eu
fiz isso mas eu comecei a pegar o
dinheiro que tinha juntado investir só
em mágica e estudando fui estudar vendas
eu já tinha feito curso de hipnose
comecei a estudar mais hipnose comecei a
montar projetos de show e foi assim por
um bom tempo até que meus pais viram que
eu não ia mudar de idéia e começaram a a
dar um apoio e eu percebi que não existe
nada que vale mais do que felicidade
felicidade vale muito mais que ouro
branco e não adianta você está numa
empresa ganhar muito dinheiro se você
não ama aquilo que você faz
eu já estou cansado de ver gente com
cara de 80 anos que falou olha eu fiz
tudo o que me mandaram eu tenho uma
empresa muito muito valiosa eu ganho
muito dinheiro eu paguei os melhores
professores das melhores pessoas para
cuidar dos meus filhos e hoje eles pagam
as melhores pessoas para cuidar de mim é
importante você achar aquilo que você
ama é o dinheiro é importante que o
dinheiro não consegue comprar um chapéu
legal você consegue comprar um acordo o
mais caro mas não esqueça do amor ter
não ter amor à vida não vale nada
você morre um pouco a cada dia pensando
nisso tudo eu montei a palestra como se
inspirava ver aquilo que se ama e eu
tentei pensar cara como eu me inspirei
foi que descobri que não existe fórmula
precificação inspiração de uma torneira
que você abre e fecha a hora que você
quiser
ela vem quando vier aproveite e quando
você descobre realmente aquilo que você
ama você automaticamente vai se inspirar
mas como eu jogava como desculpa aquilo
que eu amo simples corra riscos faça
cursos saia de casa o cara do gol graças
a me matar mas tenta sair do facebook e
pra rua conversar com pessoas
converse
ufa cabelo eu não vi mas eu acho que
quando você começa a conviver com
pessoas
você começa a a haver outros mundos
conhecer outros mundos por isso que eu
acho muito importante sarau recebe
complexidade e você ter contato com
poetas em contato com músicos ou então
se você não ama a parte artística
convivo com pessoas que amam com aquilo
que você que você queira fazer
não tenha medo de ser diferente também
não tenha medo sem igual
se você ama ser daquilo não tem nada que
vai fazer você ser mais feliz do que
fazer aquilo que você ama
então eu acho que pouco tempo já foi o
suficiente pra expressar aquilo que eu
queria eu sou desorganizado não
conseguiu montar um texto pra falar nada
então eu falei eu tenho uma idéia na
cabeça legal vou falar com o meu coração
eu vou deixar fluir mas a única coisa
que eu tenho pra dizer pra vocês a isso
confia em mim trabalho que você ama
i
é
muito obrigado
uns